each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon and welcome my name is
Kim rickets and i'm here to introduce
and welcome dr. Alvin no way who was
visiting us as part of the Microsoft
Research visiting speaker series dr.
Noah is here today to discuss out of our
heads why you're not your brain and
other lessons from the biology of
consciousness this book challenges the
assumptions underlying neuroscientific
studies of consciousness dr. noe asserts
that there is an inextricable link
between identity and environment and
that consciousness arises from
interactions with our surroundings
consciousness is not something that
happens inside us it is something we do
or make dr. Alvin OA is a writer and
philosopher at UC Berkeley is also a
member of the Institute for cognitive
and brain sciences and the Center for
new media for the last decade or so his
philosophical practice is in concern of
perception and consciousness and his
current research focus is art in human
nature he is also the author of action
in perception please join me in
welcoming of annoyed a Microsoft to
discuss out of our heads why are you are
not your brain and other lessons from
the biology of consciousness thank you
very much I'm going to begin by
discussing a sort of an everyday
phenomenon that many of you will it had
and I'm going to use that to set up the
argument of the talk in my introduction
of the book um suppose you go to an art
museum or gallery and imagine you
encounter the work of an artist whose
work is unfamiliar to you can you hear
me in the back can you hear me you
counter the work of an artist whose work
is unfamiliar to you ah maybe it's in a
style that is radically unfamiliar to
you it's sometimes I don't I don't
notice myself amplified
you know I fit oh you know that now it
is so let me just its location what now
am I is that better a little bit easy to
hear so you so the situation I'd like
you to imagine is that you've gone to a
gallery and you're encountering the work
in an by an artist which is very
unfamiliar to you it sometimes happens
when you look at it that you don't get
it this is meant to be an everyday
experience you don't get it it's it
strikes you as flat as opaque as as
uninteresting um but you look further
you don't give up maybe the friend who's
brought you to the gallery is a great
fan of this artist and she describes the
picture to you that's in front of you
and calls your attention to a certain
structure or complexity in the picture
that you hadn't noticed maybe you read
the wall plaque that gives you some
information you think about the thing in
front of you something remarkable
sometimes happens whereas the picture
was flat before all of a sudden it
reveals itself to you is having
structure whereas it was opaque now you
can see into it whereas before it was
uninteresting and on meaningful now you
see meaning and interest in it and I'm
very interested in this transformation
that occurs which we've all experienced
something like this one of the things
about this transformation is it's
clearly a transformation in you I'm
assuming that the picture hasn't changed
why you've been looking at it so it's a
transformation that took place in you
but very interestingly it is not a
merely subjective transformation by
which I mean it is not merely that you
now think we feel differently about the
thing in front of you you are now able
to see features of the thing in front of
you to discern qualities and properties
of it that you couldn't perceive before
now what is this transformation that
enables you now to see that which was
there all along but somehow not visible
to you there's a very good English word
for it it's called understanding what
happens is you acquired a certain
understanding that had to do with seeing
connections participating in a in a
conversation with your colleague
learning
something about the background in which
the piece was made and the understanding
disabled you only then first to see that
which was there all along the
understanding helped you bring the work
of art into focus as an object of
perception now I'm not here to talk to
you today about art or the perception of
works of art but the reason I give this
example is because it's intuitive and
it's easy to sort of understand what's
going on and in fact i think this
structure that I've just described the
bringing of the world in focus by
bringing practical or cognitive skills
or more generally understanding to bear
is in fact the basic structure of all
perceptual experience and the vast
stretches of human consciousness um that
is to say part of why our interests us
is precise that art recapitulates this
this kind of basic this basic fact now
you might think there's another idea
about I'm just going to stick to the
visual case because it's intuitive
there's another way you might think
about what we see or what is visible you
might think that what we see is what
projects to the eyes what we see is what
gives rise to patterns of neural
activation in your brain but I think
it's not that difficult to show you that
that's an inadequate way of thinking
about what we experience now this is a a
quicktime video produced by the French
psychologist Kevin o'regan I know that's
not a French sounding name but he has a
French psychologist and it's a
photograph it's a moving image actually
of a paris street scene a woman traffic
in the background um and the thing
that's interesting about this image is
that as you've been looking at it it has
been changing you probably very few
noticed that the car was blue here and
it gradually turned red while you were
looking at it now if I had an eye
tracking system on you I could prove
all of you that you'd actually moved
your eyes all over that first blue
gradually becoming red car your retinal
cells were stimulated by the color of
the car corresponding parts of your
nervous system were stimulated by the
color of the car but the cars color
didn't show up for you as changing you
didn't notice the change you didn't
experience the change now what more
sensual bodily basic primitive aspect of
our visual consciousness is there then
our experience of the colors of things
around us the color was changing you
looked at it you didn't see it why not
because you didn't expect it to change
because you didn't know it was going to
change because you didn't ask the
question is the color of the car
changing you didn't you didn't inquire
it and interrogate your environment with
respect to that issue your nervous
system was doing all the things the
nervous system does when it experiences
color but you didn't secure awareness of
the color change so merely projecting
into your eyes and stimulating your
brain is not enough for something to
show up for you and experience it nor is
it necessary um this is just a simple
slide with some words of English you you
see it you detect the meaning right away
this is a slightly I'm not sure how
persuasive this example really is but I
mean I like the fact that when you see
this you perceive the meaning but
there's some sense in which the meaning
isn't there what's there are these marks
or these projected images the meaning
shows up for you because of what you
know because of your background
knowledge of English so there's some
sense in which striking your eyes is not
necessary for you to experience
something something had to strike your
eyes but not the meaning you experience
the meeting but the meaning didn't
strike your eyes now it's also
interesting about this slide is that it
also allows us to make the point that I
made on the previous slide mainly that
um striking your eyes isn't sufficient
for seeing either could I just ask you
to read the slide right you said the
illusion of seeing what it actually says
is the illusion of of seeing but nobody
sees that um you'd be something wrong
with you if you had seen
it's just we don't we don't really see
that's not what we're in the business of
doing we we have a set of skills and
expectations and knowledge and we bring
that to bear and we see in this case you
look you kind of you guess you project
the gist and you don't really look any
further so the point of this is that the
world that shows up for us and and I
should say that my book is about
consciousness I'm going to talk more
about the book but the phenomenon of
consciousness for me ultimately is this
question of how things show up for us
and the way they show up for us and how
to understand how they show up for us
and the picture I'm trying to suggest is
a merely kind of projective passive
nervous system turned on by stimulation
isn't enough so if it's not enough what
what more do we need my thought is that
instead of thinking of what we see as a
matter of what projects to the eyes
think of what we see as what is
available to us now what projects to the
eyes on this kind of conventional view
light projects to the eyes and then the
brain constructs an image on my view the
question is not what happens inside us
when we're stimulated but rather what
are we able to do in the situation what
do we have access to you what is
available to us what we have access to
depends on what we know and what we can
do I have access to you I can turn my
head i vexed year I can turn my head in
a sense I have access to my mom I can
just pull out my cell phone and call her
I have access to the space outside the
room even though I can't see it now
because I know in a kind of practical
implicit way that I can just go out and
bring it interview so if you think about
our experience and the phenomenology of
our experience by by phenomenology I
mean think about sort of the lived
character of our experience we're not
confined just to what projects to our
eyes we see the meanings of words we see
the occluded or hidden parts of objects
we see in the periphery of the visual
field even though it's strictly speaking
out of view so what sort of question of
consciousness the question of how the
world shows up for us needs to be
understood as a question about what
enables us to achieve access in this way
to this extended space around us and I
think that the only full answer we're
going to give to that question
is going to be one in which the brain
the body and the environment including
in many cases the social or cultural
environment all play and explanatory
role in the story and I'll say more
about that in just a moment let me say
now um so that's kind of that's sort of
the first the first break is little
three asterixis now I go to the next
section of the talk but the transition
is this Francis Crick Nobel
prize-winning co-discoverer of the
structure of DNA many of you may know
that he spent the last portion of his
intellectual career until his death
working on the problem of consciousness
and in about nineteen ninety-six writing
in the journal Nature Creek wrote this
is pretty close to an exact quote no
longer need scientists sit idly by
listening to the tedious discussions of
philosophers perpetually disagreeing
with each other the problem of the
problem of consciousness he said is a
natural scientific problem remember I'm
a professional academic affiliation is
philosophy so I applaud Francis Crick's
thought that the problem of
consciousness is a problem for natural
science I question whether it is any
less a problem for philosophy for that
reason but more particularly i'm afraid
that Creek was um sort of self-deluded
in thinking that he had himself in his
own work when the work of his research
team somehow transcended philosophy or
left it behind in fact I think if you
look at his work and the work he did so
much of what he did actually just took a
particular Philip philosophy for granted
and indeed took it for granted in such a
way that he didn't even seem to be aware
that philosophy was playing a role in
his work so for example in his 1996 book
which was a popular book i should add
called the astonishing
hypothesis prick said you your emotions
your fears your wishes your desires are
nothing but the action of brain cells
and their associated molecules and to
add it with something of a flourish that
this idea is so far into the ideas of
most people alive today that it can
truly be called astonishing okay this is
what it said on page three of his book
now the thing I want to say to you is
that the only thing really astonishing
about Chris remark is how astonishing it
isn't that is to say it is an old idea
that there is inside of us a thing that
thinks and feels and decides it is an
old idea that you are that thing inside
of you that thinks and feels and decides
now Descartes who developed that sort of
idea thought that that thing inside of
you which you are that thinking feeling
deciding thing which you are was an
immaterial soul stuff Creek favors a
different view according to which the
thing that does all that is your brain
Creek things that the preponderance of
evidence suggests that it's the brain
rather than something immaterial that
does the thinking feeling and deciding
but what I want to call your attention
to is first the basic sort of formal
similarity of his view and the
old-fashioned view that he opposes and
second this crucial fact which is quick
were here with us he would admit in a
minute that at the current time we don't
have any clue how the brain how the
action of the brain the action of brain
cells and their associated molecules
gives rise to experience in fact we
don't have any better idea how the brain
does it then how the immaterial soul
does it so I think what this means is we
really need to try to think differently
about this whole question we need to
step back and entertain what really
would be an astonishing hypothesis
here's the really astonishing hypothesis
that I want to argue for and that I do
argue for in my book you are not your
brain it is not your brain that thinks
and feels and decides not because
something immaterial does it but because
that's just the wrong kind of thing to
ask consciousness is not something that
happens inside us it's something we
achieve or enact or accomplish or do
based on our or thanks to our embodied
and situated interaction with and
presence in the environment and my claim
is that if we expand the domain in which
we try to shape a theory from purely
neurological factors to encompass also
behavioral environmental factors that we
actually can begin to explain what
neither quick nor anybody else has been
able to explain just in neural terms
alone okay so that my idea is that
looking for neural correlates of
consciousness whereas creek understood
that term that means actually looking
for neural systems which are the
consciousness is like looking for the
internal correlates of dance you can't
understand dance in terms of an event
happening inside me dance and
consciousness are not like digestion or
to change the metaphor maybe
consciousness is more like money than it
is like digestion that is the value of
money doesn't correspond to some
molecular property of the dollar bill
it's something else it's not that kind
of thing so my thought is we really need
to rethink how we look at it and my
positive point is that if we do this we
can actually come up with very different
looking positive theories now let me say
one other thing before I kind of start
to give you some examples to kind of
show to try to make good on the promise
um
I've been I'm bit I'm an academic but I
didn't write this book for an academic
audience and one interesting experience
that I've had is I've kind of gone
around the country talking to people
about this book is they always think
that if I'm criticizing a brain theory
of consciousness what I'm really doing
is like trying to make make room for God
or something like that it's really it's
really religion vert it's like the soul
versus material of science and that's
not at all my project I'm actually what
interests me is that I want to
understand the phenomena of
consciousness as natural phenomena that
is to say as in this the purview of
science and the question is what
conception of our nature do we need in
order to do that can we think of our
nature as a saint these like cognitive
experiential nature as essentially
neuroscientific there's lots of examples
in our experiential lives and you know
this is computer scientists there's lots
of examples in our in our lives in our
cognitive knowledge lives where we know
that you can't make straight forward
reductions of one domain to another and
you can't do a certain kind of
evolutionary biology we tell stories
about adaptation and fitness if you
think of the animal is just a conjury of
Adam's right you need a certain kind of
level appropriate way of modeling your
domain and so one of my arguments is
that if we're going to make progress on
these fundamental issues about the mind
we need to find the level appropriate to
the study of mind and my claim is that
that level is not neurological but that
level is more ecological and then
another way another way of just making
this positive point just in case any of
you are inclined to label what I've said
in this way my claim is not that the
brain is not necessary for consciousness
the brain is necessary for consciousness
the question is whether it's sufficient
whether we can understand consciousness
just in terms of the brain and my
argument is that we can't and I try to
offer some positive reasons for thinking
that we can go another way and we're
over I try to show that the reason why
this Avenue has not been explored by so
many people working within the
neuroscience of consciousness even very
brilliant people like Francis Crick is
because actually they've been
straitjacketed by some unquestioned
philosophical cartesian assumptions that
consciousness is this thing
side us okay so that's the picture so
you said when you introduced me you use
the word inexplicable or something to
characterize what I said that's not my
view at all I'm not trying to mystify
I'm trying to do science I think of
myself as a member of the cognitive
science community trying to call to task
some sloppy thinking among cognitive
scientists and part of the reason I
wrote this book for a wider audience is
because I think it's such an intricate
II we need to get some fresh blood into
the conversation okay now um let me give
you I've got about 50 minutes let me
give you um three let me give an example
of the theory at work first let me
remind you of experiments that you've
probably heard about over the years
because they've been going on for over a
hundred years on reversing goggles
left-right reversing goggles are up down
inverting lenses you know if you wear
glasses what do what a glasses do they
they change the angle at which light
reaches the I they bring it to a focus
in a place where it ought to be brought
into focus you can create lenses that
more radically refract light so that in
particular you can create prismatic
lenses so that light entering from the
left side of your visual field will
systematically stimulate your eye as if
it were coming from the right side of
your visual field and vice versa what
happens when you put on left-right
reversing goggles you might naturally
assume that what happens is things on
the left look as if they're on the right
in fact if you put on the goggles what
happens is that you have a kind of wacky
visual distortion boundaries between
objects become unstable surfaces seem to
bulge and heath and wobble the visual
world becomes unstable and confusing
almost as if you'd taken a drug you know
as if there was like a street value for
selling these goggles or something why
should this be the goggles are no more
distorting the light or depriving it of
information than your regular spectacles
the light is not the glasses are not
introducing any kind of distortion so
why should it be here's here's the idea
that I've had in that my collaborators
and collaborators and I have developed
when we ordinarily move around our
movements produce sensory change if I
step forward to you the character of my
sensory stimulation is altered by my
very own movements if I move my eyes and
head I produce sensory change when I
approached an object that looms in my
visual field when I walk around it its
profile changes when I blink I interrupt
the sensory stimulation in these and
other ways there are complicated
patterns of dependence of sensory
stimulation on movement and perceivers I
proposed have a kind of implicit
understanding of these patterns of
sensorimotor dependence Kevin Regan and
I developed this idea in a 2001 paper
and a journal called the behavioral and
brain sciences and it's the main theme
of my 2004 book my thought is that when
we explore the world perceptually we use
that sensory motor knowledge to bring
the world into focus in very much the
same way that we use our conversational
conceptual knowledge to make sense of
the painting when we were in the art
gallery so now we can say with that as
background what happens when you put on
the goggles your sensory motor knowledge
that is to say your expectations your
knowledge about the way your own
movements will produce sensory change
our bashed abrogate it now with the God
wills moving your eyes has have
unanticipated unexpected consequences
the actual sensory stimulation is the
same as it was just slightly relocated
systematically be located but the way
that sensory stimulation fits in a
larger behavioral situation has been
changed and my thought is that that
change actually deprives the experience
of what we need for the experience to be
a way of being in touch with the world
around us you abrogate the sensorimotor
knowledge so you can think of experience
as having a sensory experiences having
two parts there's the input and there's
the knowledge the goggles abrogate the
knowledge okay if you wear the goggles
for a long period of time you can adapt
to them that is to say you build up new
sensory motor expectations and what
happens voila the world gets back into
focus
so now the object on the left is
stimulating your eyes and your brain as
if it were on the right but it looks as
if it's on the left okay so the message
I want to take from this is look we're
talking about a phenomenon of perceptual
consciousness we're talking about the
difference between something looking as
if it's there and looking as if it's
there right this is this is
consciousness but we're explaining it
not by looking at the intrinsic
character of neural activation produced
by the object but by the way that neural
activation is bound within a action
context or a movement action context or
a movement action expectation loop and
what I submit is that to really
understand this phenomenon to really
explain it we have to talk about the
shape of the animal the the layer of the
body plan the kind of environment in
which the animal finds itself and we
can't restrict our attention to brain
cells alone the brain is an intimate
part of the story it's not the whole
store now let me give you another
example this next example involves
animal experimentation and I realized
that some people I've set by
descriptions of animal experimentation
but I'm just going to focus on something
that actually has nothing to do with
that on murgon kasur a neuroscientist at
MIT this is work started in the 90s
going going on into the early 2000s did
did experiments with ferrets ferrets are
born in a very neurologically immature
estate and he didn't a surgical
operation on newborn ferrets where he
spliced the I in such way or they
actually performed an operation on the
ganglion cells in the retina of the
farrah so that these cells sprouted
axonal connections to the auditory
thalamus and the auditory parts of the
brain that is what would normally be the
auditory elements in the auditory parts
of the brain rather than to the visual
thalamus and visual parts of the brain
so in other words he rewired the ferrets
eyes to the hearing parts of the brain
now what happens when your eyes are
wired to the hearing parts of your brain
one possibility you might think at least
the logical possibility is that you
would hear with your eyes but that's not
what happens what happens is you see
with the auditory parts of your brain
and I have a little schematic map here
to kind of illustrate the structure of
this so normally I have through two
mappings here mapping between the input
source at the sensory periphery of the
body and the cortical area and have a
mapping between the cortical area and
the phenomena at the level of
consciousness and normally the retina
projects to the visual cortex giving
rise to visual experience and the
auditory stimulus projects to the
auditory cortex giving rise to two
auditory experience in this case you
have an event of plasticity in which
through an actual rewiring between the
retina and the auditory cortex you have
auditory cortex receiving what neuro
scientists call afferents or stimulation
from a non-standard source and
remarkably actually this error would
Norrell elegant if I'd written it like
that because what happens is auditory
cortex changes its function to adopt a
visual function okay so what explains
this change in the character of auditory
cortex actually let me let me just go
back one second and kind of try to
remind you in case I went maybe I was a
little bit too quick about this what my
logic is here right now what I'm what
I'm giving you now is a series of cases
of phenomena in which the mapping
between an experiential state ending and
a neural state is varied in plastic and
I'm asking the question given that
there's note that shows that there's no
intrinsic necessary connection between
this neural system and this experiential
stay and so given that the question then
is
what determines it what governs it what
explains the correlations that we find
why is why is neural activity in this
area of the brain experience there's
visual why is neural activity in this
area of the brain experiences auditor
and so in the case of the goggles case
what I showed you is that activation in
an area is only the experience of left
visual field rather than right visual
field because of the way it's bound up
in a larger context and something very
similar I think goes on here what makes
auditory cortex visual cortex for these
rewired ferrets is the fact that the
neural activation here varies as a
result in relation to the animals
movement in just the same ways it would
in normal visual cortex in other words
it's not the local pattern but it's the
larger sensorimotor structure that does
the explanatory work now one thing about
this case I'm kind of going fast but I
want to get a few more things out
because I expect you to have some
discussion one thing that's going on
here is this is all inside the brain
right this is what changes is the
mapping from the surface of the brain of
the retina to the interior portion of
the brain and then you've got a
resulting change in the character of
experience but I now want to give you an
example where there isn't a rewiring
inside the brain and and that would be
my final example yep the what waves
works is the reason why ferrets are
selected is that the ferrets are born in
a neurological Eve Emma chura state so
that the wiring up of their perceptual
systems anyway sort of takes time
actually humans are somewhat similar
although we're not as immature so what
happens is during the normal development
of the animal over over weeks and months
it develops these perceptual capacities
in this rewired way and you might ask
yourself how do they know this well what
they do is they only rewire one
hemisphere so that they have in a single
animal they have a trained sensitivity
to light stimulate and sound
stimulate and then they can see that
there's no behavioral difference in the
way it responds to light stimulates and
seemingly in rewire parts in the rewired
hemispheres yes quality experiences well
this is the the sixty thousand dollar
question because we can't really ask the
fair right nobody's figured out how to
talk two ferrets there are interesting
cases where we can ask see if I have a
slide for this now I'm sorry I don't
have a slide but there's a um there is a
case that's analogous to this with
humans um when blind people learn to
read Braille long-term black people
Braille is a tactile sensory problem
right it's your feeling the raised
figures it's been shown that there is
neural activation in visual cortex while
they're feeling the characters and this
is something to do with the fact that
the visual cortex is especially useful
for processing fine spatial detail but
the fact is that when they're engaged in
this tactile task there's an activation
in their visual cortical areas and
moreover and this is the interesting
point if you provide a blast of magnetic
energy to the visual cortex what's
called transcranial magnetic stimulation
just give a magnetic pulse that
momentarily interrupts processing and
visual cortex if you do that to a blind
person reading Braille they experience
tactile illusions they bumps where there
are no bumps and you can ask them so in
that case they say I'm you know I'm
feeling in the normal way when you play
with the visual parts of my brain it's
disrupting my tactile experience so
maybe we could use that as indirect
evidence that similar things are going
on here but there's a certain certain
amount of skepticism about my argument
we take the form
of questioning whether whether I have
gone far enough in interrogating the
actual character of these animals
experiences I see hands flying up now
but let me just make one more point and
then I'll close and we can have a more
freewheeling discussion okay because I
did want to give you one more example on
the table which is directly along these
lines an engineer by the name of Paul
Becker Rita has recently passed away
back in the late 60s and early 70s and
then on through the 80s and 90s devised
what he called the tactile vision
sensory substitution system he took a
camera which was worn by a blind person
and wired it up to an array of vibrators
or electrodes which were also worn by
the blind person and there was the
information presented to the camera was
transduced in such a way that the visual
information produced patterns and
vibrations on the skin so the visual
information is actually producing
somatosensory stimulation and in a very
short amount of time his subjects and
I've recently been corresponding with
somebody was in the lab when this work
was going on and described very vividly
some of the responses to me what he
found was that in a very short period of
time the person outfitted with this
so-called TV SS tactile visual sensory
substitution system was able to make
what I think one is justified in calling
visual judgments on the basis of these
vibrations so for example a person with
the TV ssf aratus could stand here and
count the number of people in the room
or say that you're sitting closer to me
than you and that you're to the left of
you now normally touch operates by
putting your body into actual contact
with something but this is visual in the
sense that it's interrogating a manifold
add to remove from your body and
moreover people who've got a little bit
trained with this could reach out and
pick something on a moving conveyor belt
and so on okay so what's going on here
so we can think of we can think of so
what if what I've what I've put here is
we can think of this in terms of three
mappings a mapping between the distal
object and the sensory periphery of the
body another mapping between the sensory
proof of the body and a cortical area
and then a final mapping between the
cortical area and experience normally if
an object or I stimulates the Isaac
activates visual cortex and gives rise
to visual experience this blue line here
signifies the TV SS machinery so what
happens with TV SS is the object
stimulates touch receptors through a
camera stimulating somatosensory cortex
giving rise to feelings of being touched
but then what's remarkable is you get
after a short period of time this
adaptation the object stimulates the
touch receptors activates the
somatosensory areas but gives rise to a
visual experience now the reason why
this is a continuation of your question
is we could argue whether it's a visual
experience or not that's kind of in a
way where the action is but if you work
with me or if you'll accept for the sake
of argument delays that it is a visual
experience then we have an interesting
question what causes somatosensory
cortex to change its function for
consciousness not the fact that there's
been a rewiring between the sensory
exterior of the body and the cortical
area because that has not been rewired
so we need to look for something else to
find out the critical factor that causes
this to happen I think that the clue is
that what the system does is it allows
you to learn new ways of interacting
with the environment new to use the term
I used before sensorimotor dependences
now your movements in relation to the
environment produce changes in a way
which turns out to be like the way in
which visual interaction with the
environment produces neurological
changes so what I say is that this is a
visual experience not because of
anything intrinsic
to the character of the neural activity
but because of this whole loop and the
critical thing I want to direct your
attention to is that that loop crossed
the boundary of the skull the distal
object is part of the loop so my I'm
going to just wrap up now and turn to
questions because we're ready and I've
gone on for a little bit too long but so
my point is this if we want a
neuroscience of consciousness we can't
just look inside the skull and it's an
it's a it's a essentially a stale
philosophical dogma that has led
scientists to think they can deidara
somehow confined to what's going on
inside the skull the brain is
contextualized it's contextualized in
the body of the animal and in the
environment our ability to perceive our
ability to for the world to show up for
us depends upon what we can do that
depends on the way we're built not just
the way our brains about but it also
depends upon the kinds of environments
in which we find ourselves the kinds of
affordances and possibilities that a
certain landscape affords us we need to
try to re-envision an empirical study of
consciousness that takes these facts
about the brain and the context of the
body and the context of the environment
seriously now one last thing I just want
to throw out a kind of robotics related
ideas since it interests this audience
may be one of the interesting things
about so much work in artificial
intelligence and robotics is it has been
geared towards creating smart cognizes
and calculators and figures out of
what's going on around them on the basis
of these impingement on one of the
claims I make in the book is that if you
want to make if you want to make a
system with a mind like ours you've got
to make a system with habits like ours
that is to say skills like ours with a
coupling to the environment like ours
that's a tall order but I don't see any
reason in principle why it's impossible
to make an artificial mind would
probably end up being something like
making an artificial life so anyway um
thank you very much for your attention
let me study all the nature of neural
processing is to be processing on the
ISIS of feature detector you know like
every function this is wonderful
consciousness and he started would meet
you it's a tricky question so then um
you know the word consciousness wasn't
sort of uttered by the mouths of neuro
scientists until very recently
consciousness was considered a sort of a
messy vague not sufficiently precise
notion for a science to investigate if
you look at the tradition of say vision
science vision science of course did
start off for example in the work of
Hubel and Wiesel which ultimately led to
the Nobel Prize in looking at feature
detector approaches in a way Cuba and
weasels work simply masks the problem of
consciousness so you've got these
internal representations but what makes
them visual as opposed to some other way
of representing the world what is it
about these cells that makes them have a
net visual effect and so this is a
question that would be would be thought
about now yes actually the man in front
of you it tried to ask before yes
in the fairies permanent wiring to
auditory section of the brain continued
to produce auditory signal all night
asked to take on both visual and the
audio work or did it go to sell solely
to the video and the audio its original
kind of second question is in the
experiment with the tactile I'm
wondering if it was used with both
people that did fly from fur that so
we're not have ever had the experience
of love of vision and people who have
become blind and so if it was the case
that those people in describing the
experience we're able to say it's I've
seen something now I know what that
means because you know I saw something
four years before mine is my
understanding um that's the first
question I think I don't know the answer
I think I had assumed I think I've
always assumed that that when the tent
when the neural resources were captured
by a visual task they stopped performing
the auditory task but um you know in
line with the question that was posed
here earlier it might be the case that
whenever these people these ferrets
rather see maybe there's a ringing in
their ears that's that's a possibility I
don't know but my belief is that there's
a kind of an absorption of the auditory
the relevant auditory cells from the
relevant hemisphere into the visual task
at the expense of auditory processing
but it actually had to go back and
remind myself of the of the facts and
then in the second case all different
kinds of subjects were used including
non blind people but the email that was
descent from to me by person named Frank
Wilson who worked in Bakke Rita's lab
said that the initial person was
somebody who'd been I think early blind
in his life but described one day with
this machinery on him he was actually a
collaborator not just a subject he'd
been he'd been working the lab all of a
sudden what he said
named that he was having a kind of
looming sensation that is it was a it
was a shock like a striking feeling of
I'm having a kind of experience which is
utterly different than the kind I'm
otherwise able to have there's another
experiment another body of literature
done by a woman by a man in Holland his
name escapes me at the moment which has
to do with audio audio visual sensory
substitution rather than tactile visual
where visual information is transmuted
in such a way as to produce tones that
are heard rising and falling through
earphones and the reason I said a woman
is that the main subject that he worked
with as a woman whom I've met and she
had been cited as a girl and then lost
her sight and she described she
described herself as being able to see
and and recognizing that it was a sight
experience that she had once known yes
theorem computing ground ball around
your hypothesis seems to be that what
this brain is going to do is determine
by its input and interesting examples
you give is that it's determined by the
input and highly abstract and
sophisticated way that about right um
one way of putting it is that I guess
you could say that although the question
is the quite the really the question is
what we what we think of as the input
how we characterize the input and how we
as theorists need to characterize the
input to understand why the system is
functioning as it is attempts to
characterize the input purely in terms
of the saying trinsic properties of the
irradiation of the photoreceptors don't
seem to get traction if its vision
abstraction so so I guess that's about
right what you said I guess the reason
I'm bulking is that one of the one of
the ideas I like it's implicit in my
presentation is that in a way the system
is offloading a certain task of figuring
out how to represent it by taking for
granted the fact that it's having these
real real world real-time interactions
with objects that sort of give it all
the information it needs as it needs it
and part of the attraction of this way
of thinking is that in a way we let we
let the world serve as its own abstract
representation of itself for the
purposes of these computations if that
makes sense yeah yes sir firstly yes
a murder in here I didn't find me the
examples presented compelling enough to
say that we couldn't explain it just in
a frame of the brain enough because I
think if you add to the visual sensory
system that we have and that the input
the brain receives the fact that fit is
also key factor in our motor system that
gives us an idea what our bodies do at
any given point you could explain the
confluence of those and how the visual
experiences versus get created because
of the position and movement of our body
just within the brain itself and I'm not
sure if you're aware of the book called
own intelligence budget Machens i
believe it's his that as original
research but i believe so synthesized to
return different other scientists this
point is pretty much that this is a very
critical component of how our brains
work is that we have this feedback loop
that that constantly tells us what we're
doing and in that sense you really will
need this environment strictly speaking
it is just the brain in its own right
has just locked up in this cage in our
skull it just happens to receive signals
from this variety of sources so you can
say you can extrapolate and say we took
the body away and just fed that same
grain the right set of signals it would
produce
yeah that's an excellent question you
should be a philosophy student yes they
don't pay enough but I think all the
work of your challenge is done by the
phrase strictly speaking because let's
fill in the details there's actually a
lovely little article I read recently by
a friend of mine named Evan Thompson and
one of his collaborator stamped named JJ
Gurkha smelly who who says ok let's take
this idea seriously and see how much we
need to build up to you know so we start
off with the intuition that you could
have consciousness in a brain-in-a-vat
let's start off the data may be just a
few cells in a petri dish well is that
going to give you what you want now got
to build up a little bit more structure
than that let's build up a little bit
more and build up a little bit more and
see how far out we need to build before
we get the right feedback loops that we
want one of the interesting things they
stay point out is that if you do get a
brain-in-a-vat that that needs to be a
pretty sophisticated that because it
needs to enable the support of the
metabolic activities of the brain it
needs to dispose of waste arm and they
make the argument that if you fill it
out a little bit more it kind of you
pretty soon what you realize you're
doing is you're actually describing a
body so you've got a brain in a body and
I would extend the argument further and
say that if you really try to think what
kinds of delicate inputs and feedback
loops sort of motor signals out sensory
signals in feedback from the motor
system back in body monitoring if you
actually try to build it out what you'll
find that you'll end up doing is
building or at least it may be that the
only way you can actually get it right
would be by building a world building a
world for the brain and that a lot of
the work is essentially done by the
world you know whenever we talk about
these brains and bats you know we always
sort of imagine something like the
matrix or or an evil all all-powerful
neuroscientist who's who is essentially
as complex as the world as surprising as
the world so so that's not a principled
response to you because
as sort of saying maybe you're right but
maybe you're not right go ahead maybe
you're right maybe you're not ready but
let me let me give you one more but let
me just make one little footnote to that
which i think is interesting and it
picks up on what I said to you one of
the things we're very bad at is
memorizing detail that's in a way the
upshot of these demos I showed you in
the beginning which are sometimes called
change blindness the old view is that we
look we scan we build up an internal
model and then once you've got that
internal model we don't need the world
we've just got our model but it turns
out we're bad at keeping model stable in
the head we don't need to keep the model
stable in the head because the world is
right there and we can sample it as we
need it and in a way quite apart from
the possibility of the scenario you give
one thought is from an evolutionary
point of view it's far more plausible to
things that we're built to be able to
suck up the information we need as we
need it rather than somehow generating
it on our own yes I see a lot of the dog
has begun
regards actually the processing of the
brain how it would process outside and
how is a particular output on the basis
of prediction of the basis of what
environment maybe and etc
yet the main theme is consciousness
right now there are probably very
familiar with Dave Chalmers to towards
unified theory of consciousness
necessities in his book that he wrote
Scylla it seems like in your talk that
the content itself of consciousness has
been sort of like push a little bit
aside in the sense that all these things
maybe through all these things that you
are described if you true only on the
other hand I don't get the sense to the
fundamental question it is wut is dis
consciousness anyway in many scientists
abba would actually even disagree with
the last column you have all your only
on your charts saying that quality a
qualitative experience actually doesn't
even exist i mean it's something that we
beauty it's a machinery the processor
things and consciousness is it arises
magically as a by-product of the you
heard that i'm sure the tournament mini
mini guides and david chung charmers
goes on to saying that actually there
doesn't seem any reason why
consciousness is useful at all for the
function of the human body it brings
forwarded here in Zone B know if you
being if you ever you know that
example if you have a man that is
exactly like men or supplements
everybody has no consciousness well if
he has a machinery will react properly
to all the impulses would behave
normally so the mystery remains what is
this consciousness that we are talking
about we are trying to pin down we want
to include maybe the metaphysical world
in the scientific but we written over
today so I have a feeling that we are
still talking about something which we
have you define which we don't know what
it is we know it's there because we have
a very strong subjective evidence of it
but we're not have any objective
evidence and then and in that the in
depth we don't have any objective
evidence of that is really the dilemma
because science only deals with your
treachery very well he has no no claim
that the enemy can do is subjective he
has nothing in its methods that can deal
with subtitles so I'm wondering if if
that particular issue has been maybe
personally omitted from from your work
ora ora or some other things I may want
to
yeah thank you very much for that
question I hope I'm it's a you took time
to articulate it carefully and I don't
want to take time now to repeat what you
said for the audience but I hope the
audience got the basic idea of your
question um the challenge is essentially
this there is a way of thinking about
consciousness where consciousness seems
utterly interior and utterly detached
from the physical and likewise there's a
way of thinking about the physical
whereby the physical world the material
world seems at least notionally at least
logically detached from a distinct from
the domain of consciousness so the
thought that you referring to with the
zombie case is that it seems as if one
could describe the layout of particles
in the universe or in a person and
specify everything and nothing follows
whatsoever as to what it is like to be
that person so you can imagine a
possible world in which somebody weren't
exactly in my state now but not having
the thoughts and feelings that I'm now
having and this is sometimes David
traumas describe this as the hard
problem of consciousness the same issue
is approached some time with the phrase
which I believe I used in my talk
briefly the idea that there's an
explanatory gap between the description
of the physical world and a description
of the domain of consciousness I have
not ignored this question I have not
pushed it to one side I have tried to
suggest an alternative way of framing
the problem so that the problem doesn't
arise what what this way of framing the
problem takes for granted is a certain
conception of the material a certain
conception of the neutral mind free
unproblematic describing the position of
every atom in the universe sort of point
of view and then the question is how do
we draw out of that some account or some
rationale for for what consciousness has
to do with it and one thing I've tried
to suggest in a way is that we're not
actually entitled to that to that
standpoint that is already the way we
think about the biological world
or the world of of the organism or
indeed of our own bodies is pitched at a
level in which there is meaningful
contrast between self and other between
purposes aims ends this is this is what
we see when we're doing when we're doing
biology if you look at a simple
bacterium we don't describe that
bacterium just as a collection of atoms
we pick it out as a player in a Drama
and it's a player in a drum it has a
certain unity it has a certain integrity
in relation to the environment in which
it finds itself it moves in the
direction of greater concentrations of
sugar because it needs to move in the
sugar not that it does it on purpose or
knows that it has those needs but
there's a there's a narrative there and
my my basic idea is that we need to
really rethink our conception of the
substrate in terms of which we tried to
explain consciousness and that when we
do rethink the substrate the problem of
the problem the mystery goes away now
you may think that's just reintroducing
the mystery at another place and maybe
it is but it's a better place and in
particular it's a better place for this
reason it finds that the mystery of
consciousness is intimately related to
the question of the mystery of life
itself and it's not we can't just take
for granted in my view a conception of
consciousness is utterly interior and
qualitative and distinct from the manner
of our interaction with the world around
us yes
so there was a point i don't remember
exactly where you did make
acknowledgement of the behavioral
sciences so I've sort of two angles of
what I have fully formulated as a
question one is I believe you're at
Berkeley right yes is that what Freud
tov Capra is um he's in the area so so
do you to work out i don't if you've
read his book hidden connections i
haven't but he brings together biology
and the behavioral sciences and social
system sciences and what i find myself
thinking through your talk is you know
this whole combination of grain body
environment and you are not your brain
there's also the whole you are not your
thoughts and there's so much in our
environment that influences our filters
of how we experience things and i think
we are challenged to distinguish between
a behavior description versus a thought
like we have sometimes get blinded by
our thoughts but our thoughts aren't
necessarily you know at accurate right
their judgments their assumptions why
not so I'm curious in your research if
you're looking at all at the behavioral
influences of your hypothesis or your
position
miss a necessary evil science but
behaviors so you you mean sort of
behaviors in the sense of um maybe bad
things that you're doing in your life or
I'm not gonna let's try I really
understanding regular bad but they are
the way in which we see and I'm using
see yeah yeah yeahs wider than just what
you yes physically see because a blind
person also you know sees and it's
influenced by judgments and if they're
not conscious of those judgments they
might really believe what they see so
they are living in their brain of what
what they believe to be true but it
might just be influenced by their
judgments or assumptions that they
haven't checked because they're not
conscious of them it just seems like
there's this other side of maybe my
personal curiosity the biology of
consciousness has to have behavioral
part that you know feels like it's in
your brain but it's not in your brain
like you said it's part of the yeah yeah
I think I have a better sense of what
you're getting at and and let me try to
relate it to something that I did
mention in that I'm very committed to
and this is the idea that um what we can
I my metaphor of consciousness is
reaching out and picking something up
you need to know how to do that you
can't pick up everything you're too far
away for me to reach out in touch now
but then of course I can walk over to
you so there's a sense in which in my
touch ability space you're in my touch
ability space you're just a bit farther
away than this and likewise we have lots
of different kinds of skills cognitive
behavioral interpersonal linguistic
conceptual sensorimotor that enable us
to achieve contact with the world around
us but we're also on my view limited by
that which we know what and that's the
importance of education and education
both in the formal sensitivity in the
sense of just growing and living that we
learn and we we can require new
knowledge and your skills that enable us
to become aware of new things and in
particular with in education I think and
this is what I began with this tells us
something about the special importance
of art
because the the natural thing that art
does for us is it puzzles us it prevents
it provides us with something which is
in some sense at a glance not master
able like the world itself it's
something which at a glance goes beyond
what we know from what we can expect or
take for granted and thus a work of art
my next book is about art actually a
work of art is an occasion for us to
acquire new understanding new skills and
and thus have new experiences and and as
I said at the beginning I actually
really think that that's kind of what
our that's the basic shape and structure
of our normal of our normal life so this
connects to your idea of where limited
in some sense we're limited for instance
another nice little angle of your
question is the experience of novelty if
something is to novel we can't
experience it it's too radical we can't
see it Schubert once said I was told
that's very easy to write a great song
you just write a song that sounds like
music people have heard before that they
haven't heard before in other words it
needs to kind of be familiar in relation
to our expectations in order for us to
even recognize it as as a good piece of
music picking up Cezanne who is the one
who broke the model of how people were
looking at our by doing something that
so broke the model that I mean he was
ostracized but actually it opened up a
new way of seeing so it wasn't decent
music so to speak that they were
familiar with by being but yet you to
write like he totally broke he but he
conducted his skirmishes at the limits
of where people knew and what they were
working so that some of us were able
some some people were able to recognize
how would he was doing was precisely an
extension of something known well he's
on to get allies here's what he did was
intelligible because he went to the I
have a section of my book actually it's
called the limits of the known world he
went the limits of the known world and
then thought about ways of going a
little farther you can't just start
start out there and the uncharted
territories it's not it's not
recognizable question okay yes the whole
behavior and how you infer things so
there is a carrion brain where you know
its neural network so you build a
connection to another one and if you do
it repeatedly then it becomes almost
like an indentation and land or water
control and screami' manscape exactly so
that you know keep down one area and
like either eyes can't see anymore you
bring it in another way that you create
you can create another landscape in
another part of the brain and that's the
plasticity and stroke victims
so one of the questions that I have is
you said you know I can touch this on or
I can I know I'm too far away from you
but I can imagine flying over to you or
I can imagine teleporting myself back
home to where I come from but I can't so
how did here at Carrie deal with that at
the imagination and what is not in the
environment what's not really applicable
you know we've no experience there's no
neural network what are we building on
there any module with two parts in my
answer to that the first is one an
amazing thing about our use of tools is
that they do extend tools extend what we
can do so if I become the master of the
tool it doesn able me to touch somebody
the other side of the room because I get
a new skill and and they've done they've
done sort of neural work on on sort of
monkey tool users and find that the
monkeys cortical representation of its
hand is enhanced when the monkey learns
to use a stick to reach farther so
actions on the stick out there activate
the brain as word touching of the hand
so we use tools to extend ourselves in
my view on concepts language are like
tools and they extend our bodies and
they extend our minds they allow us to
solve problems we couldn't solve before
and also allow us to frame questions
that we couldn't frame before and try to
do things and so your question is
exactly picking up on what we were
discussing here what are the limits of
how far we can go that's a it's a very
interesting question I think what we're
seeing with new media and new
technologies is that we can in a sort of
cyborg in way enhance ourselves to a
really different place than our
ancestors might have imagined and that's
very promising and exciting I think but
we're always in my view always limited
by what we can do all that changes is
what we can do in other words we require
the new capacity so imagination is
limited that is you can't imagine
anything although with new tools we can
begin to imagine new things so there's a
kind of bootstrapping process by which
we open up the space of possibilities
for our
new forms of life that's what I would
say I'm well thank you very much indeed